[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
un altro applauso per lei
ha peso non sono portato dietro si può
la coperta di linus
perché perché
mi rinfacciano spesso vengono dall
università che facevo il ricercatore e
che quindi ciò quel approcciano classico
da da ricercatore si infilano biblioteca
cerca le cose tira fuori dei libri dove
boh ma che c'è scritto lì dentro
questo libro degli anni 70 che mai
risolto uno schema
ma risolto uno schema nel momento
peggiore in cui puoi incontrare uno
schema no nel momento in cui non lo puoi
riconoscere cioè nel momento in cui
cerchi di uscire dagli schemi
ci avreste mai cercato la base di un
algoritmo qui dentro
forse
avete cercato qui io l'ho cercato qui ve
lo dico subito ho iniziato da questo
molto più leggero molto più
più facile 9 che ci parlo ci scrivo però
non trovavo quello è quello che cercavo
un certo punto ho pensato
ma vediamo se qualcuno ha scritto
qualcosa no su quello che realmente
interessa a me
e mi ritrovo davanti un libro appunto
degli anni settanta scritto da un certo
david bowers che non è david bowie
in sé clos fidia of automatic musical
instruments
c'è qualcuno ha scritto nel ciclo che
dia
sugli strumenti musicali automatici
ma che c'è da scrivere sistema by
the lo vai a aprire
so se si riesce a inquadrare
ok in una slide vecchio stampo questo è
un po
trovai inquadrare e ti trovi no che
questa storia è scomparsa
è una storia che non ha dieci anni non
ha vent'anni non ne ha 50 non accento
ne sa più di 2000
cioè è una storia della musica
alternativa
che fra l'altro non non trovo insegnata
nell'accademia che non trovo insegnato
nei conservatori
e che quindi è diventata indisponibile
e questo è un bel problema
perché io qui dentro ci ho trovato la
soluzione al mio schema ok
probabilmente
non so se si può
questa cosa qui non la riconoscete
o forse sì forse qualcuno
questa cosa avessi
oddio è venuto a parlarci degli orologi
a cucù
questo ancora peggio che carion hammami
povero
al già sari
fuori dalla culla europea della
cristianità del
delle scienze perché 1200
non era proprio così
una persona è prendere raccogliere tutta
tutte le basi della meccanica medio
orientale e orientale in un unico libro
che diventa un best seller in europa
cattivi brutti
dall'altra parte del mediterraneo
questa barca è una cosetta della
tipologia che si metteva nell'acqua con
la forza solo idraulica ok quindi era
green green del 1200
si muoveva e sopra vedete aveva degli
automi di automi cioè sono dei
pupazzetti ok che suonavano suonavano ok
suonavano musica
e allietavano il banchetto del principe
del signore e cesa
dura è un duro colpo no perché quando si
fa innovazione
andare a vedere che lo facevano
duemila anni fa mille anni fa è un
problema
soprattutto se poi c'è certe cose le
filtra non c'è o non c'è modo di
trovarle
poi un altro schema che è stato molto
difficile da individuare e lo vorrei
fare con voi no
c'è qualcuno è un po di tempo fa se
posto un problema proprio su cos'è la
musica no come
si può suddividere la struttura musicale
dalla melodia
sono sicuro pensata
una buona quantità di voi potrebbe
fischiettare un motivetto inventato
seduta stante mi sbaglio dai
cieli uccellino
ottimo
ma
quelli che hanno fischiato gli altri no
perché
se chiedesse a loro di prendere quel
motivetto e comporsi un brano musicale
ok strutturandolo a più voci con
l'armonia strutture
chi fischia ora
fischiato al nelson bel problema ok
quindi la risposta
la do io ok
troppo più facile fare una melodia dal
comporre un brano musicale
preso il palo in faccia ok perso tanto
tempo mancato tanto business
ok
e che succede succede questo che si
torna indietro nel tempo 1500 un signore
si chiama
galeano ok che non è l'italiano
ti dice esattamente l'opposto
occhio perché saper comporre un brano è
solo una questione di formazione quanti
di voi sanno scrivere
penso tutti
bene è la stessa cosa poi saper scrivere
detto i bei libri degli articoli è una
cosa diversa ok
ma il punto è questo
era contro intuitiva la risposta non era
così semplice non era così scontato
ok che la melodia fosse più difficile da
trasferire
ok a una macchina
terzo schema cosa avete visto
è un balletto balletto quindi
la musica
la ballerina che balla sopra un brano
musicale
siete sicuri
e se fosse la musica che è stata
generata dalla ballerina
e faccio un passo in più
e se fossero le nostre vite
con l'attivita quotidiana e facciamo a
generare la colonna sonora perfetta per
noi grazie
[Applauso]